en la sequía más alarmante en las
últimas cuatro décadas en somalia más de
un millón de personas han tenido que
huir de sus hogares En búsqueda de
alimentos y agua como este hombre de 82
años que ha sido desplazado por segunda
vez este año la gente se debilitó por el
hambre así que tuvimos que huir para
salvar nuestras vidas vine a este
campamento en baidúa durante el mes de
ramadán mi esposa murió de hambre aquí y
yo quedé en defenso todo mi ganado y
cultivos también fueron aniquilados
Aunque en ese país del cuerno de África
La sequía son comunes el cambio
climático ha generado que lleguen con
más frecuencia expertos dicen que el
pronóstico no es alentador y que la
falta de lluvias se podría mantener
hasta inicios del próximo año el
pastoreo y la agricultura sustentan a
más de la mitad de la población y con
esta temporada de sequía más de 3
millones de cabezas de ganado han muerto
dejando en riesgo a más de 7 millones de
personas por una aguda inseguridad
alimentaria además el grupo extremista
del shabat sucedido en la llegada de
asistencia humanitaria a las zonas Bajo
su control las Naciones Unidas han
advertido sobre la crisis humanitaria
encontramos que algunas personas no
están acompañadas o tienen niños que van
solos y que no tienen a sus padres con
ellos puedes entender el nivel de
situación en el que se encuentran Por no
tener una familia niños y familias
desprotegidas una madre que ha dado a
luz fuera De esta zona que no tiene que
comer creo que es muy difícil incluso
entender esa situación solicitamos a los
donantes su apoyo para ampliar todo
durante la última sequía que experimentó
somalia en 2011 una hambruna mató a más
de 250 mil personas la mayoría de las
cuales eran niños